la séance est ouverte
le contrôle analytique de la précédente
séance a été distribuée nous n'avons pas
reçu d'observation
il y en a t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas le procès-verbal est en
adopté sous les réserves d'usage madame
la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance est retransmis sur Public
Sénat et sur notre site internet ça
cassera attentif au respect des uns et
des autres et au respect du temps de
parole
la parole est à notre collègue Emmanuel
Capu pour le groupe Les Indépendants
Républiques et territoires
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président
voilà 21 mois mes chers collègues que la
France est en situation de sécheresse
météorologiques voilà 23 jours qu'il n'a
pas plu dans les départements du Nord de
la France même cet hiver la sécheresse
était-elle que plusieurs territoires ont
subi des incendies avant ça mes chers
collègues l'année 2022 a été dramatique
avec des feux violents comme chacun s'en
souvient
je veux ici à nouveau saluer les
sapeurs-pompiers pour leur bravoure et
pour leur dévouement
je veux saluer nos agriculteurs et les
nombreux citoyens qui ont aidé lors des
feux dévastateurs de cet été
ce que nous a appris 2022 c'est que
désormais plus aucun territoire n'était
épargné par le réchauffement climatique
et que les incendies peuvent frapper
même au nord de la Loire
c'était improbable il y a quelques
années mais désormais c'est devenu une
réalité à Baugé en Anjou Avivi à
Beaulieu et même dans l'agglomération en
Juine l'été dernier vous le savez
monsieur le ministre près de 2000
hectares sont partis en fumée en
quelques jours
nous devons nous adapter à cette
nouvelle donne nos moyens doivent être
suffisants face à cette situation qui
s'annonce récurrente
un certain nombre de mesures ont été
mises en place depuis octobre dernier
il reste encore beaucoup à faire très
concrètement monsieur le ministre la
question qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est
somme nous prêts pour l'été qui arrive
avec des territoires que la sécheresse
ne quitte plus
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la transition écologique que
la cohésion des territoires monsieur
Christophe Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Capu d'abord avant toute chose
je veux moi aussi puisque vous avez
commencé par là saluer les
sapeurs-pompiers de ce pays qui ont été
en première ligne l'année dernière et
dont nous savons à nouveau qu'ils auront
à faire preuve de leur courage et de
leur dévouement habituels pendant l'été
qui arrivent
72000 hectares dont 60000 de forêts ce
sont les chiffres de l'année dernière
avec une particularité c'est le fait que
c'est feu sont déplacés sur une partie
nord du territoire compte tenu du
dérèglement climatique vous avez cité le
Maine-et-Loire évidemment mais je pense
à la sarde je pense au monde arrêt
depuis le 28 octobre date des annonces
du président de la République tout un
ensemble de choses ont été faites par
l'exécutif et je le dis par la Chambre
haute et par le Sénat au travers de sa
PPL d'abord le rappel de la culture et
de la prévention des risques près de 3
millions de brochures pour rappeler les
obligations légales de débroussaillement
et astre je salue la CMP qui arrivera le
19 juin sur l'excellente proposition de
loi portée par le Sénat qui clarifiait
qui simplifie les Old qui fait en sorte
de prévoir une écho redevance incitative
pour financer des campagnes de
communication entre autres je n'en ferai
pas la publicité ici puisque vous en
êtes à l'origine
nous mettons ensuite en place une météo
des forêts qui s'est déployée dès le 2
juin dernier deux enjeux donner une
carte rappelez les bons gestes et faire
en sorte que ce soit accessible sur
l'application Météo France
90% des feux dans notre pays mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs sont d'origine
humaine et plus de la moitié sont liés à
des imprudences une étincelle un mégot
un barbecue troisième volet au-delà de
la prévention au-delà de la météo
renforcer les moyens de lutte le fond
vert c'est 100 millions d'euros
qu'auront été fléchés pour l'achat de
caméra thermique et de drones par un
certain nombre de 10 et pour la
réalisation de corridor de sécurité
enfin les sapeurs-pompiers passages de
44 à 51 colonnes de renfort passage de
38 à 47 moyens aériens on peut jamais
dire qu'on est prêt mais tout ce qui a
été fait au cours de ces derniers mois
c'est pour protéger ceux qui nous
protège
monsieur Capu
merci monsieur le ministre pour vos
précisions et vos réponses vous le savez
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et ses conséquences sur nos
territoires c'est une préoccupation
principale de nos mères qui sont en
première ligne ils ont besoin de notre
soutien les annonces que vous faites
notamment sur la prévention sur leur
approchement des moyens aériens sur le
fond vert sur les sentiers notamment
sont une excellente nouvelle et vous
savez que le Sénat sera à vos côtés pour
améliorer encore les dispositifs
annoncés
la parole est à notre collègue Jérôme
bacheler pour le gros plaid républicain
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mes chers collègues
Royal ministre quand le bâtiment va tout
va
vous avez conclu lundi le Conseil
national de la refondation sur le
logement je pense que vous êtes trompé
de discours et que vous avez conclu la
convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
fin de vie pour la pavillon individuel
fin de vie pour les investisseurs dans
l'immobilier fin de vie pour les
emprunteurs modestes
vous avez réussi l'exploit et l'oxymore
de faire un plan de relance
qui fait des économies
cela ne serait pas si grave si le
secteur de la construction n'était pas
aussi mal
en particulier vous avez oublié
toutes les mesures d'offres
rien sur les terrains rien pour
l'investissement et rien pour
solvabiliser alors madame la Première
ministre à quand le deuxième plan le
vrai plan de reconstruction pour le
terrain pour la France
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge de la ville
et du Logement monsieur Klein
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Jérôme bachel je voudrais
m'inscrire profondément en faux dans
tout ce que vous avez dit et je m'étonne
que vous soyez à ce point conservateur
d'abord le CNR a été un succès il a
permis de mobiliser plusieurs centaines
d'acteurs du logement de manière sans
précédentes ensuite ce CNR a été la
suite d'une mobilisation du gouvernement
et du gouvernement précédent sur le
logement je rappellerai le logement
d'abord ma prime rénov la rue qui est
passé de 5 à 12 milliards pendant le
quinquennat précédent et surtout je veux
rappeler les propositions faites par
madame la Première ministre d'abord des
propositions pour sortir de la crise
47000 logements vont être rachetés ou
par la Caisse des Dépôts habitats ou par
Action Logement et c'est une force de
frappe sans précédent ensuite madame la
Première ministre a annoncé le maintien
du plan du prêt à taux zéro prêt à taux
zéro qui devait s'éteindre cette
inscription se fait jusqu'en 2027 alors
que jusqu'à présent il était réinscrit
chaque année ensuite pour le Pinel
puisque vous parlez des investisseurs le
Pinel a démontré peut-être à un moment
son utilité mais ces dernières années
plutôt ces inconvénients d'abord ces
inconvénients vous savez quand on va à
la banque et quand vous propose à Paris
d'acheter un appartement à Tours et que
vous mettez jamais les pieds c'est
souvent des logements de piètre qualité
des copropriétés qui sont mal
entretenues parce que le propriétaire
bailleur n’y met jamais les pieds ne
participent à aucune assemblée générale
de copropriété et oui nous faisons le
choix du logement intermédiaire porté
par des investisseurs
institutionnels parce que les
investisseurs additionnels vont gérer
bien mieux leur logement que pouvait le
faire aujourd'hui un certain nombre
d'investisseurs ensuite madame la
Première ministre l'a dit elle a dit
très clairement vous n'avez peut-être
pas bien écouté son discours nous allons
mettre en place une lutte une lutte
contre la spéculation contre la
spéculation foncière à travers à travers
des nouvelles méthodes pour les services
des domaines pour que les services
fiscaux puissent mieux évaluer le prix
de des terrains je vous remercie
monsieur pas cher
monsieur le ministre vous appelez succès
ce que l'ensemble des professionnels du
secteur appelleraient un four non
monsieur le ministre vous trompez
l'ensemble des acteurs se sont plaints
des conclusions c'est pas parce qu'on a
beaucoup de monde que ça fait un bon
film non c'est un mauvais scénario que
vous annoncez pour la construction en
France il n'y a pas de mesure d'offre
vous l'avez restreigner je n'y peux rien
c'est comme cela et quand vous dites à
tort que la Caisse des Dépôts pas de
chance je suis membre du conseil de
surveillance de cette institution ne je
connais bien le plan elle fait pas un
effort comme jamais en 2016 déjà hélas
nous avions dû faire un effort bien
supérieur à celui là et on attendait
comme tous les Français comme tous les
acteurs comme tous les maires que vous
avez accusés de ne pas appliquer leur
plu vous avez accusé une fois de plus
les mers c'est une vieille habitude des
gouvernements macroniens et bien tous
ces acteurs attendent des vrais gestes
pour la construction et libérer la
construction vous avez parlé appartement
petit appartement c'est une mauvaise
vision du problème du logement
la parole est à notre collègue la
président Valérie d'état vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues le Conseil
national de la refondation du logement
était celui de tous les espoirs vous
l'avez dit
bénéficiant d'une concertation inédite
d'un engagement total de la part de
l'ensemble des acteurs du logement et
fort de plusieurs centaines de
propositions le CNR devait constituer un
tournant ambitieux pour notre politique
du logement face à une crise sans
précédent pourtant ce CNR a tout d'un
rendez-vous manqué les acteurs du
logement sont unanimes le compte n'y est
pas pire leur est à la désillusion et
votre déni ne change pas le résultat la
politique du logement ne semble
manifestement destinée qu'à être une
variable d'ajustement budgétaire si on
fait le bilan comptable de ce CNR c'est
plus de 2 milliards d'euros en moins
pour la politique du logement et ça ce
n'est pas acceptable c'est la
refondation du logement qu'on attend le
CNR n'était pas une fin soit déclarée
Olivier Klein pouvez-vous nous assurer
qu'il est au moins le début de quelque
chose nous dire si dès le début du mois
de juillet des annonceront faites pour
le logement et qu'un plan d'ampleur sera
enfin annoncé pour répondre à la colère
non apaisée du logement
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur Béchu
madame monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente état mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs
le logement
[Musique]
a fait l'objet d'une d'un conseil
national de refondation et je salue le
fait que vous trouviez aujourd'hui à ce
CNR des mérites que vous n'aviez pas
nécessairement trouvé au moment où il a
été lancé et je vais donc préciser ce
qu'a été le début de la conclusion de la
première ministre
ça a été d'expliquer et olivierclin a
fait juste avant elle que ce CNR c'était
pas la fin de l'histoire mais que
c'était un point d'étape qui permettait
à la fois de tenir compte de ce qui
avait été une concertation et de
regarder sur ce qui arrivait devant la
première ministre a donné un rendez-vous
à la fin du mois de juin à l'ensemble
des ministres qui sont concernés à la
Caisse des dépôts et consignations pour
aller plus loin sur un certain nombre de
sujets et je vais vous répondre au cours
de ces dernières semaines et ce sera
officialisé dans les prochains jours
nous avons établi une nouvelle
convention quinquennale avec Action
Logement votée à l'unanimité par les
partenaires sociaux vous saviez à quel
point c'était attendu vous
particulièrement madame la Présidente
Letard un certain nombre de mesures sur
le PTZ sur le BRS sur le taux d'usure
ont été précisés mais il nous reste un
énorme chantier c'est le pacte de
confiance avec les bailleurs sociaux
comment dans un contexte où il y a un
besoin de fonds propres il y a
l'augmentation du taux de livret A
comment dans un contexte dans lequel on
a rangément du foncier comment dans un
contexte où il y a un enjeu de
rénovation énergétique de ce parc nous
pouvons poser les bases à la fois du
dispositif seconde vie
évoqué par la première ministre et sur
lequel Olivier clin a déjà travaillé
depuis des mois avec l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux
vous savez aussi que la remise à plat
d'une partie de la fiscalité sur la
location souhaitée par certains elle a
vocation a été examinée avant le début
du temps budgétaire annonce là aussi de
la première ministre je vous demande de
prendre ce point d'étape pour ceux qui
l'est une occasion de faire le bilan
dans un contexte où il y a une crise des
mises en chantier qui malheureusement
n'existent pas qu'en France parce que la
hausse des coudes d'un côté et le
relèvement des taux d'intérêt de l'autre
provoque à la fois cette crise de
l'offre et cette crise de la demande
pour répondre au sénateur d'Achères
c'est donc une œuvre de longue haleine
dans laquelle nous sommes engagés il y a
eu un point d'étape il y a quelques
jours qui pose un certain nombre de
choses nous avons entendu ce qui s'est
dit il ne sait pas rien fait mais il
reste à faire
madame la Présidente
merci les propositions monsieur le
ministre issus du CNR laisse de trop
nombreuses questions en suspens et nous
avons besoin de réponses fortes en
dehors des métropoles pointe salut
comment proposez-vous de répondre aux
besoins des territoires qui ne sont pas
en zone tendus comment accéder la
propriété en dehors des métropoles quel
parcours résidentiel pour les 2,4
millions de demandeurs de logement
social
14000 logements seront nécessaires sur
le seul Dunkerquois pour faire tourner
l'industrie verte voulue par Monsieur le
Maire comment allez-vous faire
pétez-être centré Pinel supprimé
pouvez-vous nous assurer que l'accession
à la propriété restera une opportunité
offerte au plus grand nombre et non à
privilège accordé à quelques-uns statut
du bailleur privé la mobilisation du
français où et quand cuite de
l'accession sociale tous ces sujets
attention parce qu'avec ces propositions
sinon on en finit de l'accession
populaire en province monsieur le
ministre on vous fait confiance pour
demain relever seul défi faites-le
faites le vite c'est un point de départ
c'est là que vous attend maintenant le
gouvernement doit être en accord avec
ses actes et ses engagements
la parole est à notre collègue Pascal ça
vole d'Élie pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologique vous
avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre chargé de la ville
et du logement
330 000 c'est le nombre de personnes
sans abri
4,1 millions celui de mal logé
2,4 millions celui des ménages en
attente dans le logement social en
Val-de-Marne vient d'être franchi le cap
des 100 000 demandeurs de logement dans
le même temps 5,7 millions de personnes
consacrent plus de 35% de leurs revenus
au logement deux mots me viennent
souffrance et irresponsabilités monsieur
le ministre beaucoup parlent d'une bombe
sociale réduction des aPL manque de
construction record d'expulsion et
maintenant suppression du dispositif
Pinel et pourtant si le logement coûte
38 milliards d'euros par an au budget de
la nation il en rapporte 88 milliards
alors comment expliquer vous que la part
du PIB consacrée au logement n'est
jamais été aussi faible 1,5% 2021 un
record jamais atteint
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge de la ville
et du Logement monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Pascal ça vole merci pour votre
question qui me permet de compléter je
sais votre attachement au logement en
général et au logement social en
particulier et à l'hébergement d'urgence
je voudrais vous redire ce qui a été
fait dans le précédent quinquennat sur
le l'hébergement d'urgence d'abord le
plan logement d'abord c'est 440 000
personnes qui ont sont passées de la rue
au logement madame la Première ministre
l'a annoncé lors de la fin du CNR le
plan logement d'abord 2 va être lancé il
a déjà commencé cette année vous savez
que les acteurs de la solidarité sont au
cœur beaucoup de municipalités font
partie des territoires d'accélération du
plan logement d'abord et c'est 160
millions d'euros supplémentaires pendant
le quinquennat nous allons mettre sur le
deuxième planche moi d'abord vous le
savez aussi l'hébergement d'urgence fait
partie des priorités de ce gouvernement
je rappelle quand même 120 000 place
d'hébergement d'urgence en 2017 plus
encore ce soir plus de 6 millions chaque
soir sont dépensés ensuite oui il faut
continuer à accompagner le logement
social vous le savez c'est pas un bâton
de maréchal mais je suis fier d'être un
fils du logement social et d'y avoir
habité longtemps au début de ma carrière
d'enseignant et il faut soutenir le
logement social ce que nous avons fait
en plafonnant l'augmentation du taux du
livret A il faut soutenir le logement
social dans sa capacité à rénover là
encore nous avons fait une annonce
importante sur la seconde vie dans du
local de rénovation lourde qui permettra
aux bailleurs d'accéder à l'exonération
de taxes foncières sur le foncier bâti
et puis nous allons travailler comme la
rappeler le ministre Christophe vichu
impact de confiance extrêmement
ambitieux avec l'Union Sociale de
l'habitat et je peux vous assurer que
nous ne sommes pas des festifs au
contraire nous allons au signer ce pacte
de confiance dans les mois qui viennent
en tout cas à l'horizon du Congrès HLM
qui se tiendra à Nantes merci
monsieur ce vol de vie
je vais m'adresser à madame la Première
ministre vous êtes autorisé à réemployer
les initiales du CNR et face à une crise
du logement sans précédent permettez-moi
madame la Première ministre de ce que je
pense que nous pensons que devrait
porter le Conseil National de la
Résistance aujourd'hui le gel immédiat
des loyers avec une compensation pour
les bailleurs sociaux la généralisation
de la TVA à 5,5% pour la construction de
tous les logements sociaux la
généralisation des aides à l’accession
sociale à la propriété mais également
interdire toutes les expulsions sans
solution de relogement de revaloriser
immédiatement les APL tenant compte de
l'inflation et de l'indice de référence
des loyers de plafonner les prix de
vente des logements en zone tendus de
taxer davantage les plus-values
immobilières pour financer le Fond
national des aides au logement et incité
à baisser les prix de vente de durcir
les sanctions envers les communes qu'ils
respectent pas les obligations la loi
sérieux madame la Première ministre la
seule opposition la seule opposition la
conquête du droit universel au
changement je m'excuse de vous le dire
mais c'est vous et votre gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
Mika et les coulibo est ok pour le
groupe du Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur papendent
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre la grève des
personnels de l'enseignement primaire
dur depuis 5 semaines voir 6 à Wallis et
dans l'indifférence presque totale
les grévistes sont déterminés à
continuer le mouvement parce que l'État
les traitement
54 ans qu'ils assurent une mission de
service public sans reconnaissance de
l'État et pourtant en 2006 une
ordonnance du 15 février étant dit à la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et la Polynésie
française l'application de la loi du 5
janvier 2005
relative à la situation des maîtres des
établissements d'enseignement privé sous
contrat pardon
du dispositif au motif qu'il n'y avait
pas lieu de le faire car l'enseignement
du premier degré y est concédé sans que
pour autant les mettre relèvent de
l'article
l.914-1 du code de l'éducation
au regard de ces disposition la
convention de concession avec la deck
n'était pas un frein pour l'habilitation
et conformément aux modalités de
recrutement de recrutement fixés par
l'État nos maîtres sont titulaires d'une
licence des métiers de l'enseignement
ils sont agréés par l'État et signe un
contrat de travail avec le vice
électorat qu'il est gère et les paye
directement monsieur le ministre vous en
conviendrez la demande des grévistes que
leur soit reconnu le statut d'agent
public de l'État dès la rentrée 2024
avec tous les avantages liés et
parfaitement légitime les enseignants à
Wallis exploits sont des citoyens
français nos enfants sont des enfants de
la République et doivent retourner en
classe enfin comptez-vous rétablir cette
situation particulièrement injuste et
inéquitable créé aux dépens des
personnels enseignants du premier degré
en étendant la loi dite sensi à
wallis-expool
je vous remercie
on vous répond de la parole et
communiste de l'éducation nationale et
de la jeunesse
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
culimentoqué vous m'interpellez au sujet
des maîtres de et maîtresse de Wallis et
Futuna en grève effectivement de puis le
2 mai pour des raisons salariales je
rappelle qu'à Wallis et futunal les
enseignants du premier degré sont des
agents de droit privé puisque
l'enseignement est concédé à
l'enseignement catholique et que donc
c'est professeurs sont employés par des
la Direction de l'Enseignement
Catholique néanmoins c'est l'État qui
assure des rémunérations à hauteur de
4500 euros brides brut mensuel sans
compter les primes en outre ces
enseignants sont recrutés à bac + 2
contrairement à la situation ordinaire
d'un recrutement à bac + 5 je sais
monsieur le sénateur que vous vous êtes
entretenu avec mon cabinet ainsi qu'avec
celui du ministre des Outre-mer j'ai
donné mandat à la vis rectrice de Wallis
et Futuna pour que les négociations avec
force Ouvrière éducation aboutissent au
plus vite nous avons proposé des
augmentations de rémunération j'ai
également donné mon accord pour que des
groupes de travail se mettent en place
afin de comparer la situation des
maîtres et maîtresses de
Wallis-et-Futuna avec leurs collègues de
nouvelles Calédonie et que effectivement
on étudie la possibilité de leur
permettre d'accéder au statut d'agent
public de l'État vous le voyez monsieur
le sénateur nous suivons de près la
situation des quelques 150 mètres et
maîtresses concernées auquel vous faites
allusion cette situation est suivie
notre objectif c'est que les élèves
retrouvent au plus vite les bancs de
leurs écoles
merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Viviane pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre le logement va mal
c'est un secteur en crise tous les
indicateurs sont à la baisse vente de
logements mis en chantier nous vous
permis de construire dans le même temps
on compte plus de 2 millions de
personnes en attente dans logement
social un record après plus de 6 mois de
travail d'échange et de concertation les
attentes étaient fortes mais lundi soir
avait la conclusion du CNR logement la
montagne a accouché d'une souris la
colère du secteur est à la mesure de sa
déception face à un plan jugé
minimaliste et imprécis qui n'a conservé
que très peu de ses propositions les
deux copilotes du CNR logement les
acteurs de l'immobilier de la
construction et de la solidarité tous ce
centre méprisés par le gouvernement
monsieur le ministre il faut une
impulsion forte pour répondre à la crise
du logement pourquoi n'avez-vous
toujours pas pris la mesure de ses
conséquences économiques et sociales
[Applaudissements]
de la ville et du logement
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Viviane Artigalas comme ça a
été rappelé plusieurs fois ce CNR et
vous l'avez vous même rappelé a été un
moment extrêmement important de
mobilisation et de travail des acteurs
du logement et ce CNR et tous sauf un
point final c'est un moyen de travailler
de méthode de nouvelles méthodes de
travail sur laquelle nous allons nous
appuyer pour la suite néanmoins notre
priorité et c'est probablement celle de
nous tous ici c'est de construire un
parcours résidentiel aux Français quel
que soit l'état de leur compte en banque
et pour ça il faut avoir des mesures
équilibrées des mesures équilibrées en
termes d'accession à la propriété
d'accession abordables à la propriété
c'est le sens du maintien du PTZ c'est
le sens du bail réel solidaire sur
lequel nous souhaitons mettre l'accent
car le bail réel solidaire est une vraie
bonne méthode pour permettre l'accession
à la propriété pour les classes moyennes
et nous allons le booster dans les mois
qui viennent c'est le sens des
discussions que nous menons avec Bruno
Le Maire et l'ensemble des banques pour
l'accès parce que aujourd'hui une des
difficultés c'est les taux d'intérêt et
l'accès au crédit et ça rend encore plus
utile le PTZ dans cette période
particulière ensuite c'est l'accès à la
location pour ceux qui en ont besoin le
logement locatif intermédiaire c'est un
des meilleurs moyens que nous avons pour
faire le lien entre l'emploi et le
logement et c'est pour ça que nous
allons le développer dans des zones plus
grandes et nous allons y travailler le
logement locatif intermédiaire a le même
produit final que le Pinel que certains
semblent regretter enfin nous avons
décidé de multiplier par deux l'accès à
visal là aussi dans le cadre des accords
que nous menons avec Action Logement et
là encore visale c'est une mesure de
protection du pouvoir d'achat c'est la
caution à ceux qui n'ont pas de caution
passer de 1 million à 2 millions de
visales c'est extrêmement important et
extrêmement utile pour nos concitoyens
ma priorité notre priorité c'est de
d'aider les Français dans leur parcours
résidentiel et je terminerai comme tout
à l'heure par le logement social le
travail sur le pacte de confiance que
nous avons déjà commencé est un travail
extrêmement important tant sur la
rénovation que sur la production neuve
le travail que nous menons aussi sur la
hausse du livret A et la manière dont
nous compensons cette hausse du livret A
avec la Caisse des dépôts et l'ensemble
des acteurs du logement merci
madame Martigues beaucoup d'intention
mais peu de fait l'effet seront têtus
monsieur le ministre la politique du
noblement n'est pas la priorité de votre
gouvernement quelle réponse faites-vous
au milieu de famille qui peinent à se
loger dignement aucune incommation des
aides au logement encore moins du
forfait APL et pour cause toutes ces
aides ont été dépouillées durant le
premier quinquennat quelle réponse pour
les 2,4 millions de citoyens demandeurs
de logements sociaux pas de baisse de la
RLS ni de la TVA pour le logement social
alors que l'on manque de logement
abordable quelle réponse sur le foncier
rien pour redonner un peu d'autonomie
fiscale aux élus rien que pour permettre
aux jeunes d'accéder la propriété dans
les territoires qui les ont vu même
naître aucune mesure non plus pour
relancer la dynamique de la construction
perdue depuis 2017 où est la refondation
promise le ministre des contes publics a
déjà annoncé que le secteur du logement
subirait une nouvelle baisse dans le
budget 2024 la crise du logement va
s'aggraver et ce sera la cause à cause
de votre inaction
[Applaudissements]
donner la parole à notre collègue
Garrigole pour le gros du Rassemblement
démocratique sociale européen j'en
profite pour lui souhaiter un bon
anniversaire voilà
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la banalisation de la violence
dans les écoles dans les stades dans
l'espace public envers nos élus envers
les dépositaires de l'autorité publique
ou assurant une mission de service au
public est un constat tristement partagé
dans cette période émaillée de
nombreuses crises l'augmentation des
tensions et le recours à la violence
sont des signaux d'alerte à considérer
avec une immense gravité
une partie de la population y compris la
jeunesse fait aujourd'hui le choix des
extrêmes et de l'abstention qui battent
élection après élection des records
toujours plus inquiétants les signes
d'un malaise démocratiques qui s'accroît
comme d'autres je me rends régulièrement
à la rencontre des plus jeunes dans les
écoles dans les collèges dans les lycées
de mon département j'y mesure combien
malgré le travail des enseignants le
sens de l'engagement de la République et
des valeurs citoyennes peuvent sembler
éloigner de leur réalité mais j'y mesure
également la méconnaissance de nos
institutions et de notre fonctionnement
démocratique
tout ce qui va de pair avec une moindre
compréhension de la décision politique
et de ce fait une moindre acceptation
des lois et des institutions ce défi
démocratique nous devons le relever
au-delà des dispositifs déjà mises en
place qui relèvent davantage des mesures
curatives que de mesures préventives le
groupe RDSE a initié avec notre collègue
Henri Cabanel un travail collectif pour
développer le sens de lagagement et la
culture citoyenne
des propositions pour permettre à chacun
de trouver son rôle et sa place dans une
société apaisée pour s'inscrire dans un
projet commun avec des références
partagées des propositions ou
l'éducation fait figure de priorité car
l'ignorance et le terreau de la défiance
car l'école est le lieu où se forment
les futurs citoyens monsieur le ministre
quelle mesure concrète envisagez-vous
pour mettre en place une véritable
culture citoyenne à l'école je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'éducation nationale la
jeunesse
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur et rigole très bon anniversaire
à vous votre question
pose en effet
plus largement une question fondamentale
qui est celle de l'engagement citoyen de
notre jeunesse et donc au fond celle de
l'avenir de notre République et de notre
démocratie l'enseignement moral et
civique auquel vous faites allusion fait
partie des enseignements obligatoires
dispensés du CP jusqu'à la terminale et
le rapport de votre collègue Henri
Cabanel fournit un certain nombre de
points d'appui et de proposition tout à
fait pertinent j'en retire d'une part
que cet enseignement d'éducation morale
et civique doit être réellement effectif
à tous les niveaux ce qui n'est pas tout
à fait le cas aujourd'hui c'est souvent
une variable d'ajustement deuxièmement
c'est le contenu de cette enseignement
moral et civique sur lequel il faut se
pencher la connaissance de nos
institutions les valeurs de la
République la capacité à chacun de nos
élèves d'avoir un engagement éclairé les
programmes d'enseignement moral et
civique vont donc être revus et nous
allons nous assurer de leur mise en
oeuvre dans toutes les classes par
ailleurs nous devons aussi nous assurer
du bon niveau de formation des
professeurs et vous savez qu'une épreuve
spécifique portant sur l'appropriation
des valeurs de la République dont la
laïcité a été proposée et mise en oeuvre
pour les concours du CAPES et de
l'agrégation à partir donc de la session
2022 lors des oraux d'admission de ces
concours je pense aussi et enfin à la
nécessité de l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information nous savons le rôle
délétère des réseaux sociaux dans un
certain nombre de cas il est donc très
urgent de développer l'esprit critique
de nos élèves vous pouvez tant sur
l'éducation morale et civique que sur
l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information comptez sur moi monsieur
le sénateur
la parole est à notre collègue Daniel
broyer pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre l'ISF climatique
pour nous c'est oui écoutons les
scientifiques le dernier rapport du GIEC
nous dit et nous répète que l'urgence
climatique est là plus violente et plus
rapide que prévu écoutons Jean Pisani
ferry et selmafouz qui confirme l'absolu
nécessité de réorienter les financements
publics vers tout ce qui rend notre
société plus durable et résiliente
écoutons les experts et les élus dont
les écologistes qui vous interpellent
pour que les collectivités soient
soutenues plus de 25 milliards par an
doivent être mobilisés à leur niveau
pour amortir les chocs annoncés du + 4
degrés en France Monsieur le Ministre
nous n'avons plus le choix il faut faire
en disant ce qui n'a pas été fait en 30
c'est un changement d'échelle et d'enjeu
tous les leviers doivent être activés
sans attendre et sans fléchir et les
plus riches doivent être mis à
contribution d'abord parce qu'ils sont
les plus pollueurs mais aussi parce que
les 378 ménages les plus sont ceux qui
payent le moins en proportion de leurs
revenus comme le souligne la note de
l'Institut des politiques publiques
publiées hier et aussi tout simplement
parce que la transition écologique doit
se faire dans la justice sociale
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
dire comment vous allez financer la
transition et l'adaptation de notre pays
au bouleversement climatique puisque
vous dites non à un impôt vert
exceptionnel sur le patrimoine financier
des 10% les plus riches vous dites
également non un endettement pourtant
légitime pour faire face à la gravité
exceptionnelle de cette crise climatique
monsieur le ministre Aqua dites-vous oui
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
du Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Briard
d'abord je voudrais souhaiter un bon
anniversaire à Sophie prima puisqu'il
n'y a pas de raison
si on souhaite l'anniversaire des
rigoles qu'on ne souhaite pas se vide la
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques et je le dis
je le dis à dessin parce que le rapport
Pisani ferry qui fait un peu moins de
160 pages il commence par expliquer que
économie et écologie ça va pas forcément
l'un contre l'autre et que la
décroissance n'est pas le chemin et
qu'on peut concevoir une trajectoire
écologique qui s'accompagne une
trajectoire de croissance je le dis le
rapport Pisani ferry dit autre chose il
dit que ce sont pas des mesurettes ou
des symboles qui sont à la hauteur de la
marche et il explique et il valide la
planification écologique portée par la
première ministre la méthode de ce
gouvernement méthode à laquelle je dis
oui comme je dis oui elle est nécessité
qu'on fasse en sorte précisément de
pouvoir faire en sorte secteur par
secteur de proportionner les efforts
alors
vous choisissez un angle qui correspond
à deux pages sur les 160
et je souhaite
et je souhaite vous répondre en vous
disant la chose suivante
il y a pas de tabou sur la fiscalité
sauf que le débat sur les symboles il
finit par nuire à l'essentiel si
l'écologie devient le prétexte si
l'écologie devient le prétexte pour
interdire et pour taxer on va renforcer
l'impopularité de ces mesures auprès
d'une partie de la population et on
s'éloignera des objectifs l'enjeu
monsieur le sénateur broyeur vous le
savez c'est pas la transition d'un impôt
c'est la transition fiscale quelle
transition fiscale on fait quand on
passe de l'essence à l'électrique alors
qu'il y a 40 milliards d'euros qui sont
appuyés sur la TICPE comment est-ce
qu'on assure une trajectoire de
transition fiscale qui fait qu'on
renchérit l'artificialisation pour faire
en sorte de rendre possible dans un âne
assoupli en tenant compte des besoins
des territoires ruraux mais dans le même
temps en donnant aux mers les moyens de
lutter contre la dépollution des friches
comment on baisse la fiscalité sur le
foncier non bâti pour les agriculteurs
si ça doit s'accompagner de la baisse
d'une partie c'est assez réflexion
globale et collective que je vous donne
rendez-vous dans les semaines qui
viennent pour parler de cette transition
monsieur broyer quelques secondes
chez le ministre merci de me répondre
par des questions pour la crise covid
vous avez mobilisé sans compter et
c'était heureux pour la crise climatique
c'est non et ça nous choque monsieur le
ministre si la dette financière est un
sujet sérieux et la transition fiscale
une nécessité commencée par l'ISSF
climatique qui est une demande partagée
largement sur tous les bancs de cette
émission en tous les cas sur un grand
nombre de ses bancs et sur
tous les bancs de la gauche et par
beaucoup de nos concitoyens c'est la
raison pour laquelle 170 élus vous ont
demandé de créer cette ISF c'est
désormais une pétition il vous
appartient de la rentrée
[Applaudissements]
la parole est notre collègue Alain Milan
pour le groupe les républicains
ma question s'adresse à Madame firmane
Baudot je souhaite madame la ministre
attirer votre attention sur les
inégalités de traitement entre les
professionnels de santé revendent la
fonction publique hospitalière et ceux
existent dans des établissements privés
ou privés à but non lucratif en effet en
juillet 2022 vous avez décidé une
majoration exceptionnelle de certaines
indemnités horaires notamment du travail
de nuit et des heures supplémentaires
majoration reconduite jusqu'au 31 août
2023 ces majorations sont accordées aux
professionnels des hôpitaux publics il a
été ainsi accordé 531 millions d'euros
en 2023 et 760 millions d'euros cumulés
en 2022 au
929.000 personnes du secteur public
hospitalier or personnel médical ces
majorations ne concernent que la
fonction publique hospitalière à
l'exclusion des professionnels des
établissements écrivez et associatifs
qui sont eux 284000 et qui remplissent
les mêmes missions et répondent des
mêmes modalités de financement et de
régulation de leur activité la situation
de notre système de santé appelle à la
mobilisation de tous pour répondre aux
besoins de santé de nos concitoyens la
crise sanitaire a montré que des
synergies étaient possibles entre les
établissements de santé de différents
statuts cet esprit covid doit être
préservé il passe donc par la
reconnaissance de l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé de tout statut
soumis à de fortes tensions dans un
contexte de pénurie en ressources
humaines madame la ministre dans un
contexte où nous avons besoin de la
mobilisation de tous comment expliquer
ce traitement inéquitable et comment
comptez-vous être la garante de légal
reconnaissance de l'engagement de toutes
et de tous
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé d'infirmin le Bodo
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Milon vous le savez le
ministère de la Santé accorde une
attention forte à protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des professionnels des hôpitaux
dans les différents secteurs aussi à
côté des revalorisations salariales
prévues par l'accord du Ségur pour la
fonction publique hospitalière nous
avons pris des mesures en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat des personnels des
établissements privés une revolisation
socle correspondant à 183 euros net par
agent pour le privé non lucratif
c'est-à-dire un montant équivalent à
celui du public et 160 euros nets
mensuels pour l'agent dans le privé
lucratif la reviliarisation des
carrières est rémunération appliquée au
métier du soin que la fonction publique
est sur l'ensemble de la carrière
compensée par un montant global pour le
secteur privé d'environ 220 millions
d'euros les revalorisations des
carrières et des rémunérations des
sages-femmes ainsi que la prime
d'exercices en soins critiques pour les
infirmiers et cadres de santé ont
également été mises en place dans le
privé avec des financements associés par
ailleurs vous l'avez signalé en ce qui
concerne les majorations des nuits et
des gardes les mesures mises en place
suite à la mise en sur les urgences et
soins non programmé sont des mesures
exceptionnelles et transitoires
conformément aux orientations du
président de la République sous
l'autorité de la première ministre
François brome et moi-même travaillons
pour avancer vers des systèmes de
valorisation plus pérenne pour
reconnaître l'engagement spécifique lié
à ce travail de nuit nous menons
également un travail en profondeur sur
la permanence des soins il nous faut en
effet mieux associer comme vous l'avez
souligné tous les acteurs publics et
privés pour prendre en charge tous nos
concitoyens même pendant la permanence
des soins la synergie est possible elle
a été pendant l'électricité nous
essayons de la pérenniser ce sujet est
d'ailleurs débloqué dans le cadre de la
proposition de loi visant à améliorer
l'accès aux soins en par l'engagement
territorial des professionnels dont
l'examen a débuté à l'Assemblée
nationale cette semaine
ministre je voudrais quand même rappeler
ce qui vous aviez dit à l'époque parce
qu'il avait dit le ministre à l'époque à
reconnaître les suggestions
particulières attachées au travail de
nuit et à faire aux difficultés aux
tensions anticipées sur l'offre de soins
dans les prochaines semaines et
prochains mois c'est à mesure que vous
avez prise cette mesure concerne
uniquement pour l'instant dans le cas
des majorations les personnels non
médicaux hospitaliers des hôpitaux
publics et pas des hôpitaux privés ce
que nous souhaitons c'est que tous les
personnels qui travaillent de même façon
soient reconnus merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
[Applaudissements]
de Lucas de Chanel de Dina pour qu'on
s'attaque réellement au harcèlement
scolaire aujourd'hui l'émotion est forte
et la vague d'indignation nous submerge
tous et demain la question du
harcèlement risque de retomber dans
l'oubli pendant que des jeunes
continueront de souffrir monsieur le
ministre je vous ai rencontré en février
dernier avec ma collègue Colette Melo et
vous sembliez très mobilisé et soucieux
d'avancer vite et fort sur le sujet de
mettre en place certaines mesures de
notre rapport sénatorial et de veiller à
l'application du programme PHARE surtout
le territoire or ce que je constate sur
le terrain ce sont des disparités d'un
établissement à l'autre là où le climat
est apaisé ou l'effet de harcèlement
sont contenus et traités c'est lorsque
l'équipe éducative et les services
académiques se sont saisis des
dispositifs là où ça se passe mal c'est
quand cette question n'est pas une
priorité là où les moyens manquent ou là
où l'on préfère le pas de vagues il faut
savoir aussi que le programme PHARE
n'est pas toujours appliqué ou pire
n'est pas connu dans de nombreux
établissements que les associations en
sur le sujet se voit refuser l'accès à
certains collèges au motif que tout va
bien tout ceci est inadmissible et ne
peut plus durer monsieur le ministre
avez-vous enfin l'intention de rendre
obligatoire l'application des
dispositifs existants vous déciderez
vous à augmenter les moyens de contrôle
de la mise en œuvre effective des
mesures par un renforcement des
recrutements de personnels éducatifs et
médicaux sociaux qui manquent
cruellement entendez-vous renforcer la
formation des enseignants et personnels
à la prévention la détection et au
traitement du harcèlement comment
améliorer la coordination entre les
services de l'éducation nationale de la
police de la justice afin que la parole
de l'enfant soit prise en compte pour
qu'il soit et se sentent protégés et
comment comptez-vous contraindre les
réseaux sociaux à la modération
effective du flux d'information en
circulation et à la publication de
messages d'alerte à destination du jeune
public je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse
merci monsieur le Président et mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Vaneck nous avons avancé ces
dernières années en matière de lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire mais il
nous reste encore beaucoup à faire et
effectivement nous avons du pain sur la
planche nous avons d'abord fait du
harcèlement scolaire un délit grâce à la
loi Balanant de mars 2022 les numéros
308 et 30 20 ont été créés et leur
audience s'élargit la formation des
personnels a été engagée et comme vous
l'avez rappelé le programme phare a été
généralisé avec des disparités j'en
conviens à toutes les écoles et tous les
collèges depuis la rentrée 2022 nous
nous inspirons en partie du rapport de
l'excellent rapport que vous avez rédigé
avec la sénatrice Colette mélo pour
aller plus loin
voilà les mesures concrètes que j'ai eu
l'occasion
d'annoncer d'abord la nomination d'un
adulte référent
un adulte référent harcèlement dans tous
les collèges
infirmiers CPE professeur pour assurer
le suivi personnalisé et en temps réel
des situations de harcèlement
l'extension du programme phare au lycée
et d'une manière générale le fait de
s'assurer que ce programme est
effectivement mis en place dans tous les
établissements la saisine systématique
du procureur de la République en cas de
suspicion avérée de harcèlement ou de
situations préoccupantes la création
d'une équipe départementale
d'intervention dédiée au harcèlement
pour régler les situations les plus
complexes le déplacement de l'élève
arceleur suivant en cela d'ailleurs une
proposition de la sénatrice Mercier dans
le premier degré le décret a été
transmis hier au Conseil d'État et puis
enfin la formation massive des
personnels de l'Éducation nationale et
l'augmentation significative des moyens
alloués aux plateformes d'écoute 30 18
et 30 20 madame la sénatrice je suis au
premier rang avec le gouvernement et la
première ministre pour faire reculer ce
fléau intolérable que le harcèlement
scolaire
vous avez quelques secondes bien chers
collègues
en fait monsieur le ministre il y a rien
de nouveau sous le soleil tout ce que
vous annoncez existe déjà et n'est pas
appliqué ce que je vous demande c'est de
passer de parole aux actes
la parole est à notre collègue Véronique
delfabro pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame le ministre mes chers collègues
cette question s'adressait à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Justice dans la nuit du 4
juin Édouard Babel maire de manière
Villers paisible de 400 habitants dans
le Lunévillois a été violemment agressé
par 10 individus après avoir tenté de
mettre fin à un tapage nocturne malgré
cette agression profondément attachée à
ce mandat local le maire très choqué ne
démissionne pas je veux lui montrer ici
tout mon respect et lui apporter mon
plein soutien mais c'est très Nîmes
violence ne doit pas nous faire oublier
l'incendie criminel du domicile du maire
de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins ni le décès en
2019 du maire de cygnes certes depuis
2017 l'État a agi pour assurer la
protection des élus en multipliant les
dispositifs renforcement du dispositif
de protection fonctionnelle par la loi
engagement et proximité instruction de
fermeté donnée au parquet pour renforcer
la réponse pénale mobilisation accrue
des forces de police et de gendarmerie
nationale sur le terrain des élus malgré
cela la violence des élus est en hausse
de 32% en 2022 mais pas que la violence
au niveau des élus la violence en
général le constat est sans appel
monsieur le ministre votre action ne
suffit plus face à la déshumanité des
humanisation de la société qui agresse
nous policiers nous pompiers tu nous
soignants nous enseignants et nos élus
monsieur le ministre quand agirez-vous
pour faire appliquer concrètement des
sanctions disciplinaires exemplaires ou
pénal pardon pour que c'est sans fin
cette violence devenue un phénomène de
société
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge des
collectivités territoriales et la
ruralité madame Dominique Faure
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice del Fabro
avant tout je tiens au nom de la
première ministre au nom du ministre de
l'intérieur et au nom de tout le
gouvernement a renouveler notre soutien
et notre solidarité à Monsieur Édouard
Babel je tiens aussi à saluer son
courage sa détermination avoir porté
plainte et je veux le citer il le fait
pour défendre l'intérêt général de tous
les élus tiens aussi à saluer la
mobilisation du corps préfectoral de la
gendarmerie du procureur qui ont été en
soutien actifs et aux côtés de Monsieur
Babel dans cette douloureuse épreuve
alors c'est ensemble
par une très bonne coordination
que l'ensemble des services et je les
recite préférée gendarmes et procureur
ont permis au parquet de Nancy dès le
lendemain de l'agression d'ouvrir une
information judiciaire pour violents
aggravée outrage et menaces de mort sur
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique l'enquête est en cours et
plusieurs individus sont déjà
interpellés
alors les solutions vous en avez cité
beaucoup qui sont déjà en œuvre
plusieurs circulaires à la fois du
ministère de l'Intérieur et de Gérald
Darmanin à la fois du garde des sceaux
ces dernières années signaler très tôt
évaluer la menace évaluée la gravité des
faits protégé instantanément et puis
vous l'avez dit sanctionner
alors c'est tout le sens de ce que nous
faisons que nous accélérons ces 3400
référents dans la gendarmerie dans la
police des référents violences faites
aux élus qui vont à la rencontre des
élus ils étaient identifiés que par
certains élus ils ont aujourd'hui
consignes clairs d'aller à la rencontre
des élus d'être
identifié je veux aussi en profiter pour
rappeler parce qu'il y a énormément de
cyberviolence c'est surtout la
cyberviolence qui a augmenté ces
derniers mois une plateforme Pharos dans
j'ai déjà le cas monsieur la semaine
dernière monsieur le sénateur donc cette
cyber violence il y a une plateforme
auprès de laquelle tous nos concitoyens
peuvent signaler les frais et leur
gravité et elles peuvent être des
référencé donc c'est dans une logique de
transport c'est dans une logique
transpartisane que nous travaillons
actuellement veille fréquente et
proactive de nos gendarmes répond
systématique rapide et opérationnelle et
réponse judiciaire ferme et systématique
maintenant vous terminez s'il vous plaît
j'ai terminé
je transmettrai à Monsieur Babel votre
message il est vrai qu'il a été très
entouré vous avez dit plusieurs
individus avaient été interpellé c'est
une bonne chose mais quand on regarde à
Villerupt sur le dernier épisode qui
s'est passé dans une Meurthe-et-Moselle
qui est pourtant un département très
calme l'individu qui a été auteur des
faits a été interpellé 34 fois alors
permettez-moi un petit peu d'être étonné
et un petit peu de dubitative juste une
chose il y a vraiment une crise
d'autorité dans notre société ou
certains et même de plus en plus
s'affranchisent de toutes les règles
allons-nous attendre que le pays soit à
feu et à sang pour avoir une réponse
pénale implacable avec le sourire voilà
la parole est de notre collègue
Jean-Pierre Moga pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre chargé de la ville et du
logement et j'y associe mon collègue
Pierre-Antoine Lévy depuis quelques
semaines descendabri dis-le de France
sont transférés vers les villes de
province bien que le gouvernement s'en
défende le lien avec les Jeux Olympiques
et peut-être la Coupe du monde de rugby
s'impose la pratique a déjà été observée
à Rio en 2014 à Shanghai en 2010 lors de
l'Exposition Universelle avait des
dérives que l'on sait
ces déplacements chocs et il pose la
question de l'accueil et de la
compagnement des personnes déplacées
dans des régions où les sons envoyées la
pratique interroge aussi sur les liens
entre l'État et les collectivités en
effet les sangles que les mers
découvrent ces déplacements sans en
avoir été informés à l'Avon Adamo et
sans que leur avis ait été sollicité
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous en
dire plus sur les modalités de ces
déplacements comment la répartition
territoriale des sans-abris franciliens
étaient le réaliser les élus locaux
sont-ils consultés ou placés devant le
fait accompli
quel accompagnement social est prévu
pour les personnes déplacées monsieur le
ministre ne pensez-vous pas que les mers
ont besoin d'un peu plus de transparence
et de considération je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégués en charge de la ville
et du Logement merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
Jean-Pierre Maugat merci pour votre
question qui va me permettre de rétablir
quelques quelques vérités le travail
d'accompagnement en province des
personnes sans abri de la région
parisienne est un travail qui semaine
avec les associations de solidarité
depuis plusieurs mois c'est une
réflexion qui est en cours qui a l'appui
des associations de solidarité car vous
le savez sur les 200 000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence que nous devons
chaque soir plus de la moitié sont dans
Paris et oui nous ne savons pas bien
accompagner ces grands nombres en région
parisienne et il est important de
trouver de meilleures solutions en
partenariat avec le préfet de région
j'ai eu le maire de Bruz et je vous
donnerai son numéro de téléphone si vous
le voulez pour vérifier qu'il avait bien
été informé en amont oui il avait été
informé plus de trois semaines avant de
ce dispositif il faisait partie de la
concertation et bien évidemment nous
demandons au préfet d'associer les élus
locaux à cette démarche et nous continu
souvent à le faire mais oui nous pensons
que un accompagnement en petite nombre
dans nos régions parce que c'est la
solidarité nationale c'est l'honneur de
la France d'accueillir les personnes en
hébergement d'urgence parce que
l'hébergement est inconditionnel mais
nous devons le faire dans de meilleures
conditions que nous le faisons
aujourd'hui parce que l'hébergement
d'urgence dans les nuitées d'hôtel et
par pays en tâche de léopard en
Île-de-France ne permet pas cette
accompagnement social et administratif
je tiens à vous dire aussi que cet
accompagnement est fait sur la base des
volontariats avec les associations les
personnes qui sont accompagnées en
province sont informés on leur propose
d'aller en province et ensuite au vu de
leur évaluation ils pourront revenir en
Île-de-France seront raccompagnés sur
leur situation administrative dans leur
pays est insoluble et sinon resteront en
province dans des lieux de tension sur
l'emploi je vous remercie
monsieur Moga
oui merci monsieur le ministre je prends
acte de votre réponse mais vous
comprendrez qu'après l'épisode de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins il serait
regrettable de créer une nouvelle
tension avec les mers qui souvent
l'impression d'être tenu pour quantité
négligeable sans verser dans la malgame
la comparaison s'impose aussi avec la
situation des migrants là encore une
répartition territoriale et parfois
faite sans que les élus leur mot à dire
ce genre de décision je pense que vous
le comprenez doit être prise en
concertation avec les collectivités
locales pour assurer leur succès
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue malgré son pour le groupe les
républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre l'agriculture le 29 avril vous
faisiez passer le risque grippe aviaire
d'élever à modérer le 3 mai elle
refaisait son apparition dans les Landes
le grs les Hautes-Pyrénées et les
Pyrénées-Atlantiques la Calmy a été de
courte durée dans le Sud-Ouest et la
sidération depuis 7 ans chaque vague a
été plus violente tous les modèles ont
été touchés partir dans celui des
élevages en plein air toutes les
ripostes dépassées y compris la
frustration tous les territoires frappés
l'ensemble de la filière touchée ce
lundi vous annonciez entendre la
désespérance tout en confirmant une
campagne de vaccination pour octobre
prochain enfin semble se briser le tabou
autour de la vaccination à bière mais
octobre est une date lointaine
infiniment lointaine car la vie Glière
viticole est particulièrement la filière
gras du Sud-Ouest est à genoux beaucoup
d'éleveurs ont baissé les bras beaucoup
se sont endettés pour appliquer les
mesures de biosécurité beaucoup
attendent encore les indemnités des
abattages antérieurs monsieur le
ministre la vaccination n'est pas la
panacée mais c'est une réponse totale
que trop longtemps attendu la mise en
œuvre si la raison pour laquelle les
quatre chambres d'agriculture réclament
pour cet été le déploiement du vaccin
aussi en associant à cette première
question mon collègue patriciae
appliquerez-vous la vaccination aux
élevages labellisés AOP comme ceux du
pays de presse pouvez-vous préciser
quelle sera la part à la charge des
éleveurs eux qui attendent toujours le
versement des indemnisations des
abattages antérieurs enfin et surtout
peut-on dans le Sud-Ouest accélérer le
processus de vaccination
je finistre
de l'agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Brisson merci de
votre question qui me permet de faire un
point effectivement d'abord dire ce qui
s'est passé au 14 mars dernier nous
avions imaginé que nous étions sortis de
l'épisode de l'année 22 23 puisque nous
n'avions plus de cas avéré et ça avait
justifié d'ailleurs des mesures de
relâche sur un certain nombre de mesures
sanitaire malheureusement et ça avait
particulièrement bien fonctionné je
tiendrater dans votre région en
nouvelle-aquitaine puisque grâce au plan
Adour de désensification dans les zones
les plus impactées on avait très peu de
cas puisqu'on avait eu simplement 28
foyers contre 361 l'année passée on peut
dire que ces mesures elle est fonctionné
malheureusement vous l'avez dit on a
assisté au début du mois de mai une
résurgence du virus dans le Gers d'abord
puis en Pyrénées-Atlantiques puis dans
les Landes et donc on a de nouveau de la
désespérance qui s'est créé d'abord dire
qu'on a pris des mesures classiques
d'abattage dans les les élevages
infectés de des densification dans
d'autres cas et des abattages sanitaires
à l'extérieur de ces de ces de ces Périm
voilà deuxième élément sur lequel on a
travaillé c'est de regarder sur lequel
on continue à travailler c'est
d'accélérer vous avez raison il y a de
la désespérance y compris économique
d'accélérer les indemnisations qui
étaient dues et deuxième élément de
faire en sorte qu'on ait des des
indemnisations plus rapidement perçues
sur les nouveaux cas qui viennent
d'apparaître dans cette région et puis
vous-même interrogez troisième point sur
la question de la vaccination nous avons
dit que nous serions en capacité à faire
des expérimentations à partir du mois de
juin de l'an dernier puisqu'on a besoin
d'autorisation européenne on a été au
rendez-vous nous avons dit que nous
expérimenterions jusqu'au mois de mars
on a été au rendez-vous du calendrier
j'ai dit qu'à l'automne ou vaccinerions
en particulier les palmipède parce que
c'est ceux qui sont les plus touchés
nous serons au rendez-vous j'entends
l'inspiration parce que c'est impatience
c'est les nourri de la désespérance
d'éleveurs qui sont à au deuxième ou
troisième épisode mais nous sommes sur
un sujet vaccinal nous avions besoin de
qualifier le vaccin c'est fait depuis
quelques jours nous avons fait des
précommandes pour accélérer le processus
et donc on sera bien au rendez-vous de
l'automne si on peut un peu accélérer le
froid mais il faut qu'on le fasse en
bonne heure pour que s'assurer que d'un
point de vue sanitaire ça se fasse dans
de bonnes conditions
vous avez quelques secondes
je comprends les problèmes techniques
qui se posent à une vaccination rapide
alors dans ce cas il faut un plat
d'urgence sinon quand le vaccin arrivera
les éleveurs ne seront plus là merci la
parole est à notre collègue Patrick
jolie pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le 24
mai dernier à l'occasion de l'examen
annuel de la situation économique et
sociale de la France et de ses
perspectives la Commission européenne a
constaté je cite que la France est
caractérisée par des disparités
régionales croissantes qui vont au-delà
du clivage persistant entre région
métropolitaine et ultra périphérique
elle ajoute également selon ces termes
que la fracture entre zones urbaines et
zones rurales en termes de dynamisme
économique et de perspective de
croissance et devenue une préoccupation
politique et qu'il est important de
remédier au déséquilibre régionaux pour
notamment améliorer les perspectives de
croissance à long terme de la France
elle préconise enfin au conseil de
demander à la France pour reprendre sa
formulation de procéder à la mise en
œuvre rapide de programmes de politique
de cohésion en lien avec le plan de
relance et de résilience en vue
d'accélérer une transition écologique
sociale économique num érique équitable
et inclusive alors Monsieur le Ministre
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur ce
diagnostic impitoyable et savoir comment
le gouvernement envisage de répondre aux
recommandations de la Commission
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge du renouveau
démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateurs Patrice Joly effectivement le
paquet printemps de la Commission
européenne formule un certain nombre de
recommandations comme cette son habitude
de le faire d'ailleurs vous en citer
quelques-unes je vois que vous prenez
soin de ne pas noter d'autres
recommandations qui feraient peut-être
moins de succès sur vos banques comme la
nécessité de réduire la dépense publique
par exemple monsieur le sénateur nous
allons dans le sens de ce que veut la
commission surtout lorsque vous parlez
d'harmonisation du territoire entre
réalité et territoires urbain en matière
industrielle c'est tout le sens de la
politique qui est conduit depuis
plusieurs années et qui est amplifiée
d'ailleurs j'en veux pour preuve les
premiers résultats alors que nous avons
pendant plusieurs décennies enregistré
une réduction du nombre d'entreprises
dans notre pays d'industrie qui fabrique
qui produisent
pour la première fois depuis trois ans
nous réintroduisons des entreprises et
le bilan entre les sorties entre les
fermetures et les ouvertures d'usine et
positifs de l'ordre de 300 entreprises
ce qui est une bonne nouvelle et quand
vous regardez d'ailleurs vous ne vous y
trompez pas le président de la
République est allé où il est allé dans
le la région des Hauts de France puisque
c'est notamment ici qu'il y avait un
déficit encore plus important
qu'ailleurs d'entreprises qui fabriquent
et qui produisent et donc il a souhaité
qu'on mette le paquet dans ses
territoires parce que c'est une richesse
pour notre pays
ensuite vous interrogez sur les
réflexions de la Commission européenne
s'agissant du verdissement de notre
économie c'est justement là aussi le
sens de ce qu'a présenté la première
ministre le président de la République
l'ensemble du gouvernement sur le projet
de loi industrie verte et qui va dans le
sens d'une industrie des carbonée qui va
dans le sens de nous permettre demain en
français et en Europe 1 de fabriquer à
nouveau sur notre territoire les
instruments indispensables pour
participer à la rénovation thermique ce
sera quand même mieux quand on fait de
la rénovation de l'habitat des Français
de pouvoir leur proposer des pompes à
chaleur fabriqué en France ou des
panneaux solaires fabriqués en France
vous voyez on inscrit nos pas en
l'occurrence dans ceux de la Commission
on peut avoir des désaccords sur
d'autres aspects mais ce sur lesquels
vous m'interrogez je crois que l'épreuve
sont tangibles monsieur le sénateur
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre il est urgent d'agir s'ennuyer
effectivement un certain nombre
d'avancer tel que vous avez pu les
évoquer en matière de territoire
d'industrie les chiffres témoignent de
cette urgence le PIB par habitant en
Île-de-France et de 57 600 euros contre
29200 en moyenne pour les autres régions
la part de la population exposée au
risque de pauvreté ou d'exclusion
sociale s'élève à 22,4% dans les zones
rurales contre 19,2 dans les
agglomérations l'espérance de vie en
zone rurale est inférieure à deux ans à
celle constaté en ville
urgence donc à mettre en œuvre une vraie
politique d'aménagement du territoire
global avec des moyens à la hauteur des
enjeux de la cohésion sociale qui se
délitent ce qui remet en cause notre
République par ailleurs il y a trois ans
le rassemblée à l'unanimité avait
demandé au gouvernement à l'occasion de
la présence française de l'Union
européenne d'agir fortement pour la mise
en place d'une vraie politique
européenne destinée au territoire ruraux
au-delà de la PAC et à la hauteur de ce
qu'il pèse sur le plan démographique
cela reste aujourd'hui un impératif sur
lequel il y a lieu d'agir de manière
déterminée je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Cédric
Perrin pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse aux
ministres des armées même si il est
retenu à l'Assemblée dans quelques mois
se tiendront les Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 c'est une chance mais c'est
aussi une charge d'un point de vue
sécurité nous le savons et nous le
constatons tous les jours en Ukraine les
drones peuvent représenter autant un
atout qu'une menace très élevée en 2021
la Direction générale de l'armement a
notifié au consortium Thalès CS groupe
le marché dénommé parade pour doter la
France d'un dispositif de lutte
antidrone or il semble aujourd'hui que
la solution n'est absolument pas
opérationnelle je ne doute pas de vos
efforts pour atteindre le résultat qui
soit satisfaisant mais aujourd'hui avec
quel matériel je n'ose imaginer alors
que nous étions une référence au sein de
l'OTAN que nous soyons aujourd'hui prit
de vitesse je n'ose imaginais que nous
soyons contraints de faire appel à des
importations pour la protection des Jeux
Olympiques
je nous enfin imaginer que nos ambitions
de souveraineté soient rabaissées au
moment où la loi de programmation
militaire projette le contraire
monsieur le ministre l'enjeu crucial
elle a représentation nationale mais
aussi les Français et les visiteurs du
monde entier ont besoin d'être rassurés
notre dispositif de lutte antidrone
est-il oui ou non opérationnel sera-t-il
testé comme le gouvernement l'a promis
au salon du Bourget la semaine prochaine
et pour la Coupe du monde de rugby en
septembre prochain et enfin est-il bien
made in france merci beaucoup
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire d'État en charge du service
national universel madame Sarah et lairy
monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Pereira
je vous prie d'excuser je vous recherche
du regard monsieur le sénateur c'est bon
je vous ai retrouvé monsieur le sénateur
je vous prie d'excuser effectivement le
ministre des armées qui est retenu dans
le cadre du vote de du vote solennelle
de la Lepropre militaire à l'Assemblée
nationale mais monsieur le sénateur vous
avez raison aujourd'hui la lutte anti
drone est un sujet absolument essentiel
d'autant plus essentiel qu'il impacte
nos opérations extérieures et notre
sécurité intérieure encore plus dans le
cadre d'échéance particulièrement
importante à sécuriser comme les Jeux
olympiques ou paralympiques monsieur le
sénateur la loi de promo aggramation
militaire elle a évidemment intégré un
budget de défense solaire
particulièrement ambitieux plus de 5
milliards d'euros 350 millions d'euros
particulièrement pour la lutte antidrone
y seront consacrés mais aussi des moyens
supplémentaires en termes législatif
l'article 27 en particulier qui nous
permettra de renforcer le régime légal
permettant d'élargir entre autres la
possibilité de brouillage monsieur le
sénateur ou la neutralisation de drone
au titre de la Défense nationale en
s'appuyant sur des nouvelles
technologies de nouvelles menaces bien
sûr on y fera face le ministre des
Armées développe dès à présent des
innovations indispensables comme des
armes à énergie dirigées ou encore des
drones qui intercepteront évidemment
d'autres drones menaçant en tout cas
pour augmenter la sécurité monsieur le
sénateur sur le système parade que vous
avez évoqué la contractualisation a eu
lieu en 2021 il a été effectivement
contractualisé avec Thalès et CS groupe
aujourd'hui 6 exemplaires ont été
commandés en 2022 neuf supplémentaires
sont prévus dans la LPM le système est
en cours de vérification monsieur le
sénateur depuis fin avril évidemment
comme tout système d'armes complexe il
fait l'objet de quelques difficultés
mais en cours de résolution pour équiper
évidemment et accompagner nos
industriels monsieur le sénateur le
ministère des armées sera en mesure
d'assurer la protection des JO contre
les menaces grandissantes et nous ne
ferons pas appel à des solutions sur
étagères et donc ce sera des industriels
français je vous remercie
je suis très heureux que vous nous
souligner que ce seront des industriels
français qui procéderont à la protection
d'une autre ciel et de nos spectateurs
lacrologie la chronologie était pourtant
très simple il s'agissait évidemment
d'abord d'acquérir un système qui soit
opérationnel ensuite de le monter en
compétences au Bourget à la coupe du
monde de rugby et ensuite enfin de
pouvoir le l'utiliser de manière
efficiente au Jeux Olympiques
aujourd'hui le système ne fonctionne pas
il n'existe pas et moi j'essaie de
savoir comment vous allez faire pour
utiliser ce système à la coupe du monde
de rugby ce que je vous demande
aujourd'hui est-ce que je demande au
ministre des Armées c'est de faire en
sorte que le ministère des armées et la
Délégation générale à l'armement ce
coordonne pour faire en sorte que la
capacité française qui existe
aujourd'hui dans nos forces puissent
être réunies pour que chacun que les
industriels travaillent ensemble pour
que la France soit enfin à la hauteur en
matière de lutte anti-drone pour la
Coupe du monde de rugby et pour les Jeux
Olympiques ensuite merci
la parole est à notre collègue Stéphane
piennoir pour le gros plaies
républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre après les déclarations
successives d'un certain nombre de vos
collègues la première ministre a
confirmé ce lundi que le gouvernement
envisage bel et bien l'interdiction de
du remplacement de chaudière à gaz dans
l'ensemble du parc immobilier et cela
dès 2026 à l'issue d'une concertation
avec les acteurs de la filière
l'objectif de décarbonation de notre mix
énergétique et maintenant largement
partagée même si la France ne contribue
qu'à hauteur de 1% des émissions de CO2
dans le monde et il faut bien sûr
trouver des solutions rapides et
concrètes pour aller dans ce sens mais
certainement pas comme le dira le
président de la République pour emmerder
les Français
or cette mesure pénaliserait très
lourdement les 12 millions de foyers
français qui se chauffent actuellement
au gaz puisque les solutions
alternatives comme les pompes à chaleur
coûte environ trois fois plus cher
qu'une chaudière à gaz performante cette
mesure déstabiliserait également toute
une filière qui est en pleine mutation
et qui attend des marques de confiance
pour continuer à promouvoir la
production de biogaz sur notre sol en
réalité notre pays a besoin davantage de
constance dans la parole de l'État et
surtout d'en finir avec une politique
écologique punitive qui multiplie les
interdictions madame la ministre
pouvez-vous préciser les attentes et les
intentions du Gouvernement dans cette
concertation avez-vous la volonté
d'entendre les arguments de bon sens qui
dans la concertation qui débute
pour vous répondre la parole dans la
ministre de la transition énergétique
madame panier renacher
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur piennois alors je vous rassure
il n'est pas question d'emmerder les
Français il est surtout question de
planifier et de donner de la visibilité
à l'ensemble des acteurs que vous avez
cités à la fois les Français qui
aujourd'hui ont des chaudières fossiles
et de l'autre côté toutes les filières
qui sont autour de ces installations et
je vais me permettre de remettre
peut-être cette concertation qui est au
stade de concertation dans son contexte
comme vous le savez le président de la
République nous a confié une mission et
un objectif ambitieux en matière de
transition énergétique être le premier
pays à sortir des énergies fossiles pour
tenir ses objectifs de neutralité
climatique à horizon 2050 c'est pourquoi
le gouvernement travaille sous l'égide
de la première ministre secteur par
secteur a trouvé les voisins
systématiques de construire cette
neutralité carbone
évidemment il y a le secteur du bâtiment
le secteur du logement et notre objectif
c'est d'avoir des logements moins
énergivores moins émetteurs de carbone
c'est une nécessité pour notre planète
mais c'est aussi plus de confort et
moins de factures pour les Français moi
émetteur de carbone cela veut dire de
logement consommant moins de gaz et
moins de fuel pour être chauffé ou
refroidie ce travail vous le savez il
n'a rien de nouveau je rappelle qu'il
n'est plus possible par exemple
d'installer des chaudières gaz et des
chaudières fuel dans les constructions
neuves et que nous avons arrêté les
installations les soutiens
l'installation de ce type de chaudière
mais nous devons aller plus loin c'est
pourquoi nous avons avec mes collègues
Christophe Béchet Olivier Klein lancez
une concertation publique mardi sur la
décarbonation du secteur du bâtiment et
notamment sur l'accélération la
décarbonation des moyens de chauffage
cette concertation elle va nous
permettre de travailler sur des
solutions concrètes et accessibles
accessibles en prix vous avez mentionné
le point il est tout à fait valide tout
en anticipant la montée en puissance
dans nos usines d'alternatives et de
fabrication de de nouvelles types de
chaudières à carbone c'était également
mentionné par mon collègue Olivier Véran
à l'instant il ne s'agit donc pas de
prendre des décisions drastiques et
immédiates gouverner c'est prévoir
prévoir c'est anticiper c'est ce que
nous faisons au bénéfice des Français et
de nos entreprises monsieur piennois
il y a qu'un jour votre collègue le
ministre Christophe Béchu disait ici
même qu'on en avait fini avec l'écologie
punitive
s'il vous plaît donc je vous demande
simplement n'ouvrez pas la voix une
nouvelle colère sociale ne faites pas
payer aux Français les Allemands et les
volts face de l'exécutif c'est ces
dernières années nous nous savons tous
de quoi nous parlons ne laissez pas les
foyers les plus modestes supporter une
mesure qui est totalement déconnectée de
leur réalité au quotidien je vous
remercie
bien merci madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres nous
en avons terminé avec les questions
gouvernement nos prochaines questions
auront lieu le mercredi 14 juin à 15h je
vais suspendre la séance extra reprise à
16h30 pour l'examen d'approvision de loi
maintenant provisoirement dispositif de
plafonnement de revalorisation de la
variation annuelle des indices locatifs
on ne quitte pas le logement la séance
est suspendue